how are you doing today
hi how are you i'm doing excellent i
want to start with what you i'm sure
you're hearing from every person you're
speaking with
uh which is you did a phenomenal job
with this i
just want to say congrats thank you so
much
i have a lot of questions but i have to
start with the most important thing
right up front
uh as a huge fan of prince i cannot
imagine
what it was like getting to perform with
him and i'm ju
yeah i'm just curious can you sort of
talk about getting that chance to sing
with him because
i i as a i don't know if your career can
get better than that because that's
amazing
prince is one of my favorites honey let
me say that to you so i'm already about
to scream that you asked this question
but do you know when i got to sing with
him when i realized like oh my god i'm
on the stage of prince i literally
screamed
in the middle of the performance okay i
was like
oh girl you sing it lord i'm on the
stage prince
okay i
i i've watched your performance with him
and a
you you've you brought it and b
i i just i can't imagine what what that
experience would have been like
i just really can't can i add one more
thing to that when
okay so when we performed together we
didn't get a rehearsal i'm trying to
make this quick because i know you get
along
anyway so he's like you're gonna come up
on the lift and we're gonna be on the
stage that was all i had i was like i
know the song i'm gonna learn it inside
of now so whatever i get out there it'll
be
so i get out there and i'm singing
anyway
and in there in the performance he says
jennifer take it to church i didn't hear
him say that
right later i see the performance long
after he's gone
and i was like he said take it to church
and i didn't hear him
so when i got to do the tribute to
prince um after he passed
all i heard in my mind was jennifer take
it to church that's all i heard was
prince voice and i'm like
i'm gone i got you so
this is it for me okay all right i
i could again i could talk about that
the rest of the time but getting to talk
about your
amazing work and this i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of a movie
things you don't really hear about what
do you think might surprise people to
learn about the making of respect
i think this film was done differently
everything was
live to tape like the music was live
this is and i've done a lot of musicals
so i've never seen it done this way
um i love that everything felt like a
celebration because
everyone who was there was there on one
accord we was there out of love and
respect and admiration for miss franklin
so it felt like a a celebration in a way
a majority of the time what else can i
add
i don't know that's the name of you yeah
sure i'm i am curious you uh you worked
earlier in your career on dream girls
with
bill condon and i'm curious if there's
anything that you took
from that experience that helped you
with this performance in this film
um using everything whatever you're
feeling
in this moment in that experience and
bill used to always tell me i
love bill you're mentioning all my
favorite people in life okay
i just want you to know that um trusting
myself
like they always say your instincts is
always dead on trust yourself
so i will having bill you know
teachings everything teaches you and
prepares you for the next
so i pull from a lot of things for
respect
for from my experience and drink girls
yes uh i'm always curious about uh
people that sing
how the hell do you keep your voice
fresh
and going especially when you're making
a movie like this where you have to
deliver
you know songs and really give yourself
how do you keep it
so it doesn't fail you on an important
day
um sleep one being that's the key
because if you if you ain't getting
sleep your voice gets tired and
you're already starting half empty and
keep singing like that was the thing
they like she's still singing and you
know what
that was another way how i got dream
girls because bill condon was like this
girl been out here for six hours and she
lost her voice she's still singing
so it's a muscle the more you sing the
stronger it gets
so i like to sing and sing and sing and
sing my way through it all
with and and that gives it jeopardy in
the voice
i have to stop there again i really want
to say congrats on this movie
you did such a great job thank you